I was born in Pennsylvania but I grew up
in Connecticut no yeah I was born in
Pennsylvania and then I lived in
Connecticut then I moved to Florida no I
had a hundred K on Instagram that's
great oh that's cool
but anyways so then I went to college at
Florida State and it was the best like
it's such a party school yeah absolutely
not you guys left it oh but thank you I
did this diet once and it was so good
like I swear by it and maple syrup and
it was so good I swear by a Beyonce that
is amazing she's my role model is you're
so addicting oh how was the shoot
yesterday it was awesome we had a hair
stylist the Hohner looks like Barney
threw up all over your hair I'm sorry
anyways huh I can't hear a word you're
saying with your stupid accent I'm sorry
okay I cannot stop eating these they're
so addicting you should probably stop
eating those I'm getting kind of fat oh
I'm sorry oh oh I'm sorry
hmm those punches per week
hey Mac you messed up again
Amanda can we speak to you in the living
room please you sure can bring Jack Shaw
so Amanda you know we love you right
yeah we're worried about you Amanda
hi we're fine Amanda how old is forever
young tell me how old you are older I'm
sorry we have the same birthday oh yeah
how old are you 17
this is a game okay and imaginarily kill
imaginary jack breasts yes we can't
that's rude we can't hear it's fake it's
imaginary guys it's rude my friends here
what did you say Jack was here oh god
now she's in the Titanic oh we should
help it
Amanda what is that over there let's
just be friends soos guys what's wrong
oh no I just waxing our eyebrows can't
hurt that bad have you ever tried this
before easy
oh really cuz this really hurts guys are
weak oh you think you're so tough see my
face this is the face of a man that
doesn't get scared let's give it a go
easy whatever all right
one two three
[Music]
hey guys it's me Amanda Cerny thank you
so much for watching my certainiy skits
and liking and commenting
I literally read every single one of
them so thank you guys the team journey
is growing and I love it and when it
involve you guys even more so what I'm
doing now is I'm taking Sarnia skits
suggestion ideas ain't you just comment
below any good ideas that you have for
me
and if I decide to choose your idea that
will shout you out in my next Cerny
skate youtube video so keep the comments
coming and who knows it could be you
love you guys and I'll see you next week